en los últimos vídeos he estado
criticando el plan geithner mostrando
que si actualmente el mercado quiere
pagar racionalmente 30 dólares por un
título por una acción incluso con la
opción de venta gratuita que está dando
el gobierno lo más que podría pagar o
que quisiera pagar una inversionista
racional por estos bienes será de 40 a
50 dólares lo que sigue sin llegar al
precio que pide el banco para poder
vender estos bienes y quitarlos de sus
libros hemos visto en varios vídeos que
si los bancos venden estos bienes por
menos de 60 dólares por ejemplo pues los
bancos se volverán insolventes irán a la
bancarrota así que no están dispuestos a
vender esto por menos de 60 dólares y
este es el caso en el que el plan no
funcionará y tenemos el otro escenario
en donde estas acciones están siendo
compradas por 60 o 70 dólares y con base
en algunos argumentos que di en los
vídeos anteriores las únicas personas
que estarían dispuestas racionalmente a
comprar estos bienes a más de 60 dólares
en los mismos bancos al crear algún
inversionista medio desequilibrado en su
hoja de balance y hay muchas maneras en
la que pueden crear este tipo de
organismos aunque muchas personas me han
escrito oye cómo es posible que los
bancos puedan comprar sus mismas
acciones que venden se puede dar un
préstamo no recursivo a algún fondo de
cobertura que se acaba de crear y ese
fondo de cobertura es el que compra los
títulos y de hecho casi todos los fondos
de cobertura en el mundo tienen alguna
relación con algunos de estos bancos por
lo que sería casi imposible de es
asociar a los inversionistas privados de
los bancos principales que están
tratando de deshacerse de estos bienes
pero en este vídeo quiero hablar de una
característica positiva que tiene este
plan de geithner y ese argumento es el
que dice que en este momento estos
bienes se están echando a perder y
tenemos a todos estos bancos que están
queriendo vender estos bienes y todos
están sufriendo de problemas de liquidez
así que tenemos esta enorme cantidad de
oferta de
los títulos y justo ahora todos los
posibles compradores naturales de estos
títulos son muy poquitos ya que ahorita
todos los bancos están viendo forzados a
vender estos títulos para poder pagar
sus préstamos así que todo esto se está
volviendo un caos por lo que la demanda
por estos títulos es muy poquita así que
aquí tenemos una demanda muy pequeña y
justo esta es la razón por la que
tenemos esta desconexión en el mercado y
que la gente solo quiera pagar 30
dólares por estos títulos ya que tenemos
esta falta de liquidez
hay mucha oferta muchos bancos vendiendo
estos títulos y los poquitos compradores
que hay pues no están dispuestos a pagar
demasiado por éstas y es un argumento
que hemos venido escuchando varias veces
que esos 30 dólares no es el precio real
ya que cualquier persona que observe
estos títulos que se han llamado y con
razón bienes tóxicos o títulos tóxicos
se darán cuenta que estos no valen ni
siquiera los 30 dólares no están dando
rendimiento a lo mejor su precio real es
de
7 dólares o 20 dólares mi opinión es que
si este es el caso lo que el gobierno
debería hacer en lugar de dar opciones
de venta gratuitas a los fondos de
cobertura y básicamente subsidiar los
bienes bancarios o peor permitir que los
bancos hagan esa trampa que les
practique en los vídeos anteriores donde
pueden comprar las cosas que ellos
venden ellos mismos usando el dinero de
los contribuyentes lo que el gobierno
debería hacer es aumentar la
transparencia de estos títulos por lo
que este conjunto de compradores aumente
en ese momento estos títulos son daños
colaterales de obligaciones o respaldos
de hipotecas o bonos de algún tipo y las
personas que pueden comprar bonos no son
muchas son solo un pequeño grupo de
inversionistas profesionales la mayoría
de los cuales están bloqueados
con este debacle crediticio por lo que
lo que yo propongo que se haga y
permítanme aquí dibuja una pequeña hoja
de balance aquí están los bienes estas
son las obligaciones aquí está el
equilibrio
tomamos estos títulos tóxicos
y ponerlo en una compañía
esta es una corporación
por lo que aquí van esos bienes tóxicos
esa corporación tendrá un conjunto de
acciones
si todos los bienes tóxicos vienen de
este banco y se le dan estas acciones a
este banco de regreso y noten que esto
no es hacer trampa el banco aún tiene su
bien tóxico en su hoja de balance pero
en lugar de tener el viento físico
directo allá tiene las acciones de esta
compañía y la razón por la que estoy
haciendo esto es para que vean que se
puede tomar esa compañía y entonces
incluirla en un intercambio tradicional
y estamos hablando del gobierno de los
eeuu del tesoro de los eeuu y ellos
pueden hacer que esa corporación se
muestre en el intercambio de acciones
nueva york- y sólo con hacer esto se va
a aumentar significativamente el grupo
de inversionistas que puedan interesarse
en esto pues justo ahora las únicas
personas que pueden interesarse en estos
son las personas que compran bonos lo
cual no es algo trivial invertir en
bonos tienen que invertirse en
incrementos de 1000 dólares cuando menos
normalmente son bloques mucho más
grandes de dinero y algunos de estos son
obligaciones de deuda colateral es lo
cual ya los hace difíciles de invertir
cuando se quiere invertir en ellos y
bueno esto resolvería hasta cierto punto
el problema de tener más personas
interesadas en comprar y ese segundo
problema que francamente es el peor es
que no se sabe que hay en estos bienes
tóxicos
el problema que ocurrió en este reciente
incremento de venta de bienes raíces es
que se les dieron préstamos a personas a
las que no se debía de prestar dinero y
lo que hicieron es tomar y rebanar todos
estos préstamos y eso ya lo hemos visto
en vídeos anteriores
toman un grupo de hipotecas millones de
hipotecas las ponen en una estructura
corporativa y después las rebanan en
diferentes troncos y eso lo expliqué en
el vídeo de obligaciones de deuda
colateral ese tronco se paga primero
este otro tronco se paga después y este
tronco se paga hasta el último así que
cualquier pérdida
este grupo lleva las de perder en su
mayor parte estos son los bienes tóxicos
aunque algunos de estos otros también se
han vuelto tóxicos el problema con estas
cosas es que la razón a la que se han
vendido es que fueron a moody's y les
dijeron dame una calificación sobre
estos títulos y moody's dice bueno esta
es una calificación triple a aunque no
la llamarían así pero podrían decir
bueno este es un título tipo b y creemos
en la palabra de moody's de que ese de
aquí es un título triple and pero la
única razón por la que moody's dio su
aprobación a estos títulos es que las
mismas personas que están estructurando
esto y recibiendo todo el dinero de esto
son las mismas personas que le pagan a
moody's lo que necesitamos hacer aquí es
quitar al intermediario a las agencias
calificadoras y el gobierno no sólo
tendría que crear estas corporaciones de
manera que se puedan comprar estos
bienes sin ser un negociante de bonos
simplemente comprarlas en el intercambio
lo que el gobierno también tendría que
hacer es contratar a un gran equipo ya
que aquí estamos hablando de cientos de
miles de millones o incluso billones de
dólares así que es necesario contratar a
un equipo que esencialmente publique una
página web donde se mueve
qué es lo que hay exactamente dentro de
cada uno de estos títulos digamos que
esta compañía que acabó de crear tiene
un código identificador abs de así que
lo que podemos hacer es ir a esta página
web buscar por este código
esta empresa abs de y la página me dará
toda la información de lo que hay en
este título tóxico conozco a muchas
personas que son inversionistas
profesionales y que están en una
posición de que si ellos quisieran
podrían comprar estos títulos tal cual
están pero están temerosos ya que no
saben exactamente qué contienen estos
títulos tóxicos no saben si son
completamente fraudulentos o no tan
fraudulentos y en muchos casos es muy
difícil saber si hay algo que respalde
esos troncos así que lo que el gobierno
tiene que hacer es hacer todo este
proceso lo más transparente posible
deberían tener un mapa de los eeuu y
deberían decir bueno estos títulos
corresponden a casas que se encuentran
en la parte superior de nueva york-
estas otras se encuentran en florida el
30% está aquí en nueva york'
el restante porcentaje está en florida
también debería mostrar tablas y
gráficos de manera que si yo soy un
inversionista pues puedo extrapolar esto
puedo generar modelos de manera que
pueda darme una idea si vale la pena
invertir en esto existe aquí es quitar
la opacidad lo opaco de todo este
procedimiento por un documento de miles
de páginas que sólo pocas personas lo
pueden entender y ya que los
inversionistas estén decididos a
invertir en esto pues puedan ir con su
negociante de bonos local y hacerlo en
cambio aquí bueno creamos esta compañía
esta compañía se publica el intercambio
de títulos new york' y hacer
completamente transparente lo que hay en
esos títulos tóxicos por lo que
cualquier persona viendo esto puede
decir sabes que yo creo que esto
realmente vale unos 40 centavos de dólar
no 30 centavos de dólar y en lugar de
tener que invertir millones de dólares
se pueden comprar 100 acciones por 400
dólares no sería una inversión demasiado
grande si se hicieran esto pues con esto
se resolvería el problema de liquidez ya
que este grupo de compradores se
volvería más
y ni el gobierno ni los bancos podrían
dar este argumento de que estas son
ventas de pánico y que estos bienes a 30
dólares están muy por debajo de su valor
ya que se tendrían a muchas personas con
información real y con acceso real para
comerciar con ellas y poder asignarle un
precio más real a estos títulos y así
cuando se ve a uno forzado a marcar el
mercado y ya que se tienen todas esas
acciones en ese título que se están
ofertando en el n y ese se tendrá un
volumen mayor de transacciones y la
marca de mercado que nos vimos forzados
a hacer en estas pues esencialmente
acciones ahora pero bueno sigue siendo
lo mismo son las acciones en nuestro
bien tóxico pero estás en el mercado
tendrán mucho más valor y se tendrá
mayor información en el mercado sobre su
valor y si a pesar de todo resulta que
estas acciones sólo valen 30 centavos de
dólar o 30 dólares pues dejemos que los
bancos se vayan a bancarrota y
continuamos con nuestras vidas ya
habíamos comentado que podríamos crear
nuevos bancos u otra solución pero
que no deberíamos estar jugando esta
charada de cuánto valen estos bienes y
si deberíamos subsidiar a los bancos o
estar dando opciones de venta gratuitas
a los fondos de cobertura y detener todo
esto opacó la solución es exponer todo a
la luz del día y dejar que el precio de
mercado muestre lo que realmente valen y
si la realidad muestra que estos bancos
deben irse a la bancarrota pues dejemos
los irse a bancarrota